Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. Thank you everyone that submitted questions for the Arrow and Flash Q&A this week
Lots of stuff happening becuase we're getting so close to the Finale
Including the first reveal of what Katana's costume's gonna look like
There's also some news about the Spin-off show, supposedly, Victor Garber did an interview
where he revealed that it would premiere sometime in January
and it was going straight to series
there hasn't been any confirmation on that
but that is in line with a lot of the rumors we've been hearing about the show
So what  they might end up doing is premiering the Spin-off series with the back half of Arrow and The flash
meaning that as we get the last 10 or 13 episodes of Arrow and The Flash next season
they'll also air the episodes of the Spin-off series
They said they haven't shot the Pilot yet, but
supposedly the cast has gotten together, so
hopefully they'll have like a promo ready for the finale of The Flash or Arrow
Comic-Con is like just around the corner
so, they'll probably have some more news around that time
So on to questions, here we go
First one:
Well there's two ways to look at this
One is that the AI was lying to Barry when it said that He created it
or two: the Reverse Flash stole it from Barry in the future
The actor that played Eobard Thawne is going to be back before the end of series, so
what I'm hoping is, is they do a flash forward and we get some of Eobard Thawne's back story
In this last episode he said "nothing is forgiven"
Implying that The Flash did something to slipe the Reverse Flash, or something to harm him
That seems like something they would eventually show us before the season finale
Next question:
So, you're wondering like if Barry's gonna see a future where everything's gone crazy
and there are a bunch of supervillains running around
No, I don't think that that's gonna happen
If they're gonna end up being more like they are in the comics, like
their super powers or super tech in the case of Cisco
I think that they would show us that in present day first
I do think we'll see flash forwards
Like, Barry probably will time travel in the future at some point
Maybe in season 2
But I don't think they'll go full terminator, where you see like the post-apocalyptic waste land
Like the dark alternate future if something goes wrong
Danielle Panabaker did say that she had a flashback in last week's episode
that showed a colder version of Caitlin, and that
was gonna be like a Killer Frost type joke
But supposedly it got cut from the episode
Next question:
Well, so, if you remember, the shield was just designed to keep people moving at super speed out
So, anybody who wasn't a speedster could pass through
So, metahumans, regular people-- anybody
It wasn't that he was vibrating his way through, like
he literally just stepped through as if he were stepping through a doorway
Next question:
So, just to give like a broad explanation, you're probably talking about the alternate timeline
I was gonna do like a real quick once-over for what's going on with the series
So, what you have is
Eobard Thawne from the 21th century going back in time to Barry as a child to try and kill him
to prevent him from becoming The Flash
Future Barry, from 2024, learns about it, goes back to fight him that night
prevents him from killing young Barry
As a consolation, Eobard Thawne kills Barry's mother
then gets stuck
That night's about fifteen years before present day on the show
Which is also about ten years before the crisis in the newspaper
So, in the original timeline, you know, before the show started
The Flash became the Flash around 2020 and then 4 years after that they had the big crisis
Eobard changed that, so we're already in like the second timeline
Then there's the third timeline created when Barry time traveled earlier this season
the one where Cisco died
Barry went back in time that week, altered events so Cisco did not die
but, like Eobard said, if you try to change the past to avert a disaster, time will find a way to
replace that disaster with something just as bad
That's like the show's way of explaining why Barry just doesn't time travel all the time
So, hopefully that helps a little bit
The alternate timeline, the one that Cisco's remembering
isn't gonna merge with the present timeline or anything like that
they're just gonna keep remembering it
Next question:
Well, I mean, I kind of answered that like a little bit in the last question
but no, the reason why I don't think that Flash is just gonna change time and erase half a season of arrow
is beacause that would be a huge WTF from the writers' room
It'd be like a giant middle finger to all of us that have been watching Arrow for the last six months
Like saying "hey, all these stuff we had these characters do, that doesn't matter, we just wiped it clean"
that would be like the laziest writing you can possibly do
So, whatever ends up happening with Oliver, I think they'll resolve that on Arrow
He does team up with The Flash, but we don't know if League Oliver here
is still brain washed or if he's been fixed
and he just happens to be wearing that costume still
Right on like the list of big questions that need to be answered in the next couple of episodes
that's still like really high on the list
Next question:
That's actually a really good question and I saw a lot of you asking that
What happened to future Barry that went back to stop young Barry from being killed?
The simplest explanation is that he was erased
when they changed the past, when Nora Allen died
because in the original timeline Barry just grew up and became The Flash in 2020
So, short answer: that future Barry ceased to exist the minute Nora Allen died
Next question:
So she was in the future newspaper, when they were talking about the crisis
you know, whenever they give the big justice league shout out
But, for those asking about that future newspaper
specially like the Wayne tech merger, justice league
there are some things that they can do on the show
some things that they will never be able to do
So, you just have to remember that sometimes when they do easter eggs like that
they're just winks and sometimes they're actually setting something up
Hawkgirl we know is in the Spin-off, so that's you know more Teeing something up
Batman-Superman-Wonder Woman, probably never gonna be on The Flash or Arrow
I don't think that they would ever do Justice League or DC would even let them do Justice League
If they do Justice League in the future, it'll probably just be as a turner phrase
like they'll just reference the Justice League
The spin-off show will be like a proto-version of the Justice League
Interestingly enough, they still have not settled on a final title for that yet
Even though "Legends of tomorrow" is like the rumored working title
I don't think that's what it's actually gonna end up being
Next question:
I'm assuming you're talking about The league of Assassins- Oliver Queen - Nyssa arc
No, it doesn't mean she won't ever be on the show
It just means that Nyssa is always gonna be like the top tier sister
The producers did a Q&A a while ago where people were asking about Talia Al Ghul, they're like "does she exist in this universe?"
They said "well, she doesn't not exist" they just haven't decided how they want to integrate her
When they do eventually mention her or show her, she's always gonna be a fringe thing
Katrina Law is gonna be like the go to actress
So, if there's like a major arc involving the League of Assassins or one of the daughters of Rha's Al Ghul
it's always gonna be based on Nyssa's character
The practical reason for doing that is that it doesn't cause them to step on a lot of Batman cannon toes
As much as they change from the comics, they're still trying to honor the source material
Next question:
That is Katana, straight out of the comics, like right of the page
There's a few things they have to explain, like they have to explain how she ended up in that comic book costume
All we know of her in the flashbacks, are that she has some skills and she uses a blade
what I think happened is they intended to do like a big Katana arc, and the actress just wasn't available
So you get to this big finale moment, where they're like "Here is Katana from the comic books"
And you're like "Wait, where has she been this whole time?"
"How did she get in that costume? Where did it come from?"
There's only two episodes left so, we'll probably find out what's going on with that costume next week
Next question:
Actually, Mark Guggenheim did address it on his Tumblr
He said that if they did that, there wouldn't be a story
He was kind of half joking, it's the same reason why Barry can't just come in and fix all of Arrow's problems for himself
that there wouldn't be a TV Show if they did that
So you have to watch with like a certain suspension of disbelief
Like these characters are gonna solve their own problems
every once in a while they might get some consulting help from team Flash
If you wanna get like really technical with the ARGUS stuff, you could say that Amanda Waller is busy with something else
I have a feeling when they bring Damien Darhk on the show next season, or
even at the end of this season
they'll weave him in and blame a lot of the larger problems that have been happening to the characters
on him
Like, they've already tied him to the earthshaker machine
So, if you're wondering why mega organization with lots of weapons resources are tied up
and they're not helping team Arrow more
is probably beacause they're fighting H.I.V.E.
Next question:
I assume that you're talking about the Omega weapon
He wants him to release the virus to kind of clean the city, sort of speak clean his past
That's what he said, he might have ulterior motive
He might be manipulating Oliver to get rid of something in Starling without actually telling him the truth
Or option B: he could be completely genuine
wipe your previous life clean so that you can become someone new
Don't worry though, there can be no, you know, mega weapon storyline
without five or six shocking twists before the finale
so, we'll probably get some more information that'll add some more context as to why Oliver has to do this to Starling
Thank you so much everyone for submitting questions
These are always a ton of fun to do
I know there's been a whole bunch of big news going on lately
Right now, if you ever wanted to see what it looks like, when like
the online Hollywood comunity takes a dump on someone
just look at Josh Trank on twitter, I feel really bad for the guy
There's a lot of rumors going around that I don't want to spread about them, cause they
could be false, but he left the Star Wars project and now everyone is just like
taking a dump on him
That's one of the really bad things about leaving a big project
Like if Zach Snyder ended up departing before he made Justice League
That's typically when like Studio PR machines come in and start pounding all the rumors
like, big 800 lbs gorillas
Speaking of which, I actually just posted my trailer video for Grodd lives
That episode is gonna be so much fun
you have no idea, he's probably gonna be a big thing in season 2
You can click here to watch that, if you haven't seen it yet
And, if you guys have seen Age of Ultron, I did a breakdown with spoilers in it
You can click here to watch that
Or if you just want spoilers
Thank you so much for watching, evereybody let's high five, I'll see you guys tomorrow